this is this show has the most
flashbacks of well look at Boba Fett's
thank you
oh
those are clone troopers
oh I can't believe we're seeing these so
this is like during maybe a month or two
of time where this must have happened
wow oh my God tomorrow Morrison Square
Morrison and all your clones that's
whose face was doing that how could you
do that Tam uh you heard you heard the
original Clem welcome back to new rock
stars Star Wars and or episode 7 proves
an old Florida Maxim no one's less
forgiving than a beach cop oh oh it
turns out you voted um that's a six gear
sentence now sorry
um well uh cassians flashback to his
stepdad Clem's death reveals it was
clone troopers could we see a
live-action bad batch on this series
where are the bad batch now well you'll
get your answers when you fix this in
the door this is Wookie leaks our weekly
reaction to the latest in Star Wars and
our and or after show I'm Eric Boss my
Easter egg breakdown of Andor episode 7
is coming tomorrow but right now I'm
here with Tommy Bechtel Eric I watching
this episode I could not wait to talk to
you about it because
it had it had a little bit of everything
for us uh pawn shops uh politically
Intrigue at a party uh being private and
exclusionary at a party pouty children
and of course Beach culture
this might be the first time we saw
beach chairs in the Star Wars Universe I
really love it also a news broadcast was
that the first time they've yeah I think
so I think that was uh the first time
like I would imagine all
telecommunication in the Star Wars
universe is through Holograms yeah but
this is just like a flat screen and a
guy like on like a kind of a Soviet set
yeah like the the the Central Committee
has reported the normal levels of
radiation from this there's nothing
wrong going on right now you can just
leave your life don't question anything
bullet go back to your brain you go bed
forever American forces are brainwashed
why are they speaking English and
Russian accent you ask my wife's because
this is what's called a bit hey Mephisto
get out of this show
um this episode is interesting let's
break it down because hey we know these
episodes come in three episode batches
um and uh so we're at the start of a new
arc here uh but unlike the past two arcs
I'm not really sure exactly where this
one's going because a lot of things are
happening at once and they're all very
interesting
um so in this episode uh just to check
in with cereal car and he takes a new it
looks like a data entry job from Uncle
Harlow to work at the Bureau of
Standards uh and yeah this is the first
time we see a TV news broadcast uh there
everyone's talking about all Donnie
everyone's freaked out about it looks
like he's taking in um a position about
fuel impurity was that the department he
works in yes he's just happy to start
from the ground floor
um this clerical manager seemed to be
pretty willing to expunge his record a
little bit uh like he seemed to admire
this uh this bureaucratic uh
go-to-itness that uh Cyril card is
exhibiting here
um and he joins this vast floor of
cubicles uh which many of us uh even
those of us who didn't see things like
uh Terry gilliams Brazil yeah it can
relate to and we've all worked in jobs
like this before and you do feel like a
face in this in the sea of people yes
major Star Wars Cameo wolf you Lauren uh
we know this guy from A New Hope where
he was initially unnamed but since then
on the Animated Series Clone Wars this
guy showed up left and right he's a very
very big deal of Star Wars I'm very
surprised to see him show up here uh he
gives this speech to the ISB he tells
him that the emperor has approved
um basically unleashing the ISB to to
crack down on everything they're gonna
raise criminal sentencing uh they're
going to Levy these taxes on any
perceived to be Pro partisan sector
detrimero privately worries this is
playing right into the rebels hands
which uh is is a she's one of the
smartest characters on this side of it
because that is exactly what Lutheran
wants I like how we see the extremists
on both sides and there's these internal
debates on both sides she orders a
search of All-Star systems for stolen
equipment from Naval bases this pisses
off blevin which also reveals that this
attendant that she asks and she said hey
can you just keep this to yourself he's
like yeah yeah sure hey uh blevin
um this woman keeps uh asking for things
and I don't know what to do about it uh
blevin hmm big mistake here he rats her
in front of everyone big swing you would
think he'd be smarter than like uh but
maybe he's just he's overconfident
um rats are out in front of party cats
and uh we find out that party cats drew
the borders of all these Imperial
sectors which is interesting because
she's calling into question the whole
system
um but Miro basically delivers particats
what he wanted which is actual evidence
to support her Theory and he sides with
her reassigns more Lana one to her uh
but he does warn her to watch her back I
think part of cats is an interesting
figure I this would have been more
shocking of a turn from him if we didn't
have you Lauren coming in because Lauren
kind of gives a different level of
authority and that kind of puts part of
gats in his place yeah a big episode
from on mothma Man visits Lutheran
reveals that she didn't know the aldani
operation was happening argues with
Lutheran over this decision to escalate
the conflict and Luther just is still
pretty giddy over all this and says that
people suffering we'll have to be part
of all this Tommy were you surprised
that mod makma didn't know this was
happening I'm very surprised I I I I I I
guess I with all of the differing uh
Empire empirical or imperial empirical
Imperial forces their levels of concern
and knowledge I forgot that the
Rebellion also probably had different
levels of of Intel and who knows what
what's going on it just seemed from the
their first meeting that they were
planning everything together they were
kind of co-conspirators so I was it was
very surprising to me um also just
interesting that mon mahma is part of
the Rebellion but funding it but hasn't
really fully thought through the reality
of what that funding would mean in that
terrorism from a certain point of view
is definitely going to be part of this
Rebellion uh and you know what they did
not terrorism like she should meet uh
sagarira that guy is freaking crazy they
just robbed a lot of money which is
definitely a big step in escalation yeah
but like yeah I love how we learned that
Lutheran is uh playing some 3D chess
here because
um yeah that is part of his plan he no
he doesn't really care so much about the
money which obviously is going to make a
dent in a lot of ways to be able to
apply that to certain benefits but like
really he just wants the overreaction
from the Empire he wants all the star
systems to to have like their kids get
unfair sentences while they're having
like a beach party they're like what the
hell is wrong with this uh system let's
you know join a rebellion and it works
we see how it works because like uh you
know Marva over on ferrics is like hey
yeah I can uh I'm a retiree now I can uh
I can join a rebellion I can do a little
rebelling yeah I um I in San Francisco I
walk through this area called the
Panhandle and like you know maybe once a
week there's like a group of protesters
who are just on the corner of the
Panhandle it's right by Golden Gate Park
who have these anti-war signs and I'm so
amazed by this group people I'm like wow
there are so many things to protest
right now but you guys are still
fighting the good fight from like the
70s because yeah we are in freaking
endless Wars and we are always fighting
Wars and it's freaking crazy that like
we're able to move on from it although I
don't know if they're anti-war because
they don't want us to intervene in
Ukraine actually I don't really know
what their politics are now that I
realize that I haven't really stopped to
talk to them that much I just like how
old they are yeah and they're so vicious
about this one topic I have no idea what
I'm talking about I'm just gonna move on
um but uh
we follow Lutheran's assistant Clea
meeting with Val sartha who cleans up
nice it turns out and uh Clea tells her
that she needs to hunt down casting
enter she tells uh she tells Vel his
actual name and um they need to make
sure that stolen trawler stays buried
Belle really wanted to see Luther which
is interesting I I'm back to thinking
that they might be father and daughter
they have some kind of History there's a
brief shot on aldani proving that Santa
is still alive she reacts to the arrival
of an Imperial Star Destroyer whoa
Monmouth hosts a dinner party where she
enlists her childhood friend from
chandrilla take Homa to head up a
charity front for her to move money
around uh Tay is more outspoken in his
anti-imperial views and assumes Monmouth
is pro-empire
um which tells us how successful she's
been in her deception but I'd be if I
were to take Oma in that party looking
around I I don't think I would be so
like well you know I'm not a fan of
of this fascist dictatorship unless I
know you are unless
he was simply playing his own spy games
when last yeah yeah unless
unless we'll talk about that in a bit uh
Cassian returns to pharynx where he
pitches leaving the plant to Marva and
B2 emo but the money he's gained yeah b
b is so sweet he's like Cassian like
he's he's like a dog or like a little
kid is or you know Uncle cassian's home
what a sweetie so uh Cassian meets Bix
at her shop he does the shape of the
haircut uh knock I know and I wanted
Roger Rabbit to just jump out and go
is
I love that shaving a haircut exists in
Star Wars it's just a little Knack it's
a little thing but he chats with Bix and
he learns that not only is Tim dead but
the whole town blames Cassian for this
new Imperial control over it
um Cassian recalls his stepfather Clem
trying to prevent other protesters from
attacking clone troopers we see this
flashback and then he gets arrested and
hung by those clone troopers
um this uh ends with Cassian storming
some of those clone troopers with the
wrench that must be how he got arrested
uh Marva says that she's staying on
ferrics because the news of the aldani
robbery inspired her to join the
Rebellion it's such a sweet moment
because cassian's like but I'm gonna
worry about whether you're okay and she
just goes that's just love can't do
anything about that yeah what a
beautiful line what a sweet line like
even as an adult she still has to
explain to him exactly how love works
because he in his life was like adopted
so late yeah they were just figuring out
like first off a language barrier but
then just like getting by a a in a
war-stricken world and that he was like
in prison for a lot of his youth so like
yeah she just had to explain this to
this adult man yeah worrying about
people that's that's called love yep
Cassian takes his money and he flees to
niamos or Miami
he's got a beach resort area with some
jamming Tunes oh my God yeah I uh you
know you see a tropical location this
might be one of the first Star Wars
locations including Hoth that I would
never ever want to go to like people are
sweating the the beach doesn't look fun
it just kind of looks like stun Sun
streaked uh I mean this is this is Miami
yeah Miami like it gets like
romanticized but when you visit there
you're just like when is my flight out
of here leaving I I couldn't agree more
I also envisioned just about a hundred
yards off camera a a elderly nudist
resort with a young Max Rebo
jamming the two oh
I gotta get out of here someday and go
to Tatooine
and he's faking a shower uh to count his
money and she's just like hey go to the
store and get them get the free flows I
need more of the flea flows I know it's
not flea flows it's piezos but like I
need a Visos like what is this red ones
you like the green ones greeny greens
[Music]
um and he's like all right fine I'll
just get out of here oh god
um but this ends up being a big mistake
you don't go out for a walk in Florida
no one just goes out for a walk you get
in your car and you drive places you go
from air conditioning building to air
conditioned building and you never just
go for a walk uh but uh he gets pulled
over by the Storm Trooper who thinks
he's involved in another crime uh this
Stormtrooper leaves Cassie into the
clutches of a KX unit it's not k2so
which is another KX unit uh Cassian gets
uh basically just like hang on to him
for a bit like you don't use UVA Ms Subs
with a KX unit he's gonna take it
literally tries to strangle and show
welcome uh we get this uh it's I mean
this is just like classic Florida
traffic court right I mean this is
triggering me back to like oh wait what
that's a crime in this state yeah yeah
yeah it's all we decriminalize random
things here uh but there's a reason why
we criminalize this because when when
crazy Florida man moved here and then
tried to do this uh and we didn't
realize that that was an evil thing that
could be done and now we have to have a
lot for it so yeah sorry you're not
allowed to pet a raccoon because uh
Florida man wants um corrupted an Army
of raccoons so Cassie gets sentenced not
to six months which I thought six months
would have been yeah insane um prison
sentence a bunch of six years due to the
Empire's new harsher criminal penalties
for his anti-imperial acts but I guess
like any crime you could say is
anti-imperial that's the insanity of
this it's like oh you oh you did this
well that shows disrespect to what the
Empire is trying to do so you know six
years let's just start with this
question of the clone troopers in this
episode because this episode proves that
the authorities who killed uh Cassie and
stepfather Clem were not Imperial
Stormtroopers were either clone troopers
and why is this distinction so important
well bad bat shows how shortly after the
Clone Wars ends Grandma Tarkin decides
to phase out clone troopers in favor of
Stormtrooper recruits uh but there was a
very very brief transition period at the
start of the Empire when Palpatine's
speech in Revenge of the Sith broadcast
to all the clone troopers the clone
troopers were still at that point tasked
with carrying out the Empire's will but
this is a period when this pharynx
flashback takes place the Empire hasn't
yet assembled a new Army from
Stormtroopers and is still using the
clone troopers to set up Imperial flags
and Insignia and chain codes and all
this stuff but that also means that the
guy who killed Cassian andor's stepdad
will have the face of Tomorrow Morrison
which just so that it's sad to think
about that that Tim was doing this right
now because whenever we think of
Tomorrow Morrison or anybody who looks
like him uh D Bailey Baker it's always
like that we're also on the good side of
the clone troopers you know our friend's
a bad batch and Rex and Echo and fives
and all these guys and then our poor
homeless to more Morrison yeah
I forget about him that's right so it's
just it's sad to see one commit war
crimes but since Andor is flashing back
to these early Empire days and is
willing to include clone troopers at all
just gives me hope that we might see or
at least learn about the Fate at the bad
batch maybe see it tomorrow Morrison
Cameo as uh one of these characters
somewhere this season uh now I I think
what Andor has trained us not to be on
like Cameo right right right we got you
Lauren show up here because Lauren is uh
he's not a b player he's a very very
important figure to the empire into Star
Wars but like he's not one that like all
fans will be like giddy to be like oh
yeah yeah turn [ __ ] yeah
um he's he's a specific kind of Cameo uh
do you think we'll learn about the bad
Batch's fate uh in this show I just feel
like the cameos we are getting from Tony
Gilroy our visual cameos more than they
are uh canonical characters coming back
so like you know we get the KX robots
we've I I feel like we might see a
Wookie or two I don't I just don't think
he'll give us the bad batch because
there's still too much to pack into the
show right like we still have we only
have five episodes left of this season
mate I mean and it would have to be this
season right because then they're gonna
time jump in the and then they would uh
it may not make as much sense so I don't
know what do you think yeah I think we
may get like signs of maybe when they
meet sagarea as partisans that we may
find out that the bad batch ended up
part of the Rebellion playing a very
specific role that helped them out in
the Rebellion uh I would hope uh I think
it'd be awesome if a member of soccer
era's partisans is just one of the bad
batch or or a clone troop yeah because
if you say it's just one of the bad
batch we're gonna wonder where the
others are all right but like I think
it'd be so cool if like there's a clone
trooper if there's like Rex it was just
part of his yeah because he really does
gather a random who's who of of crazy
Freedom Fighters so I I really hope that
that be like just the fact that they're
willing to show us clone troopers just
because it's such a specific era of time
to have clone troopers who are serving
the Empire right they were really only
talking about like less than a year I
think because Tarkin pretty quickly
phased them out like see someone a bad
batch goes into that whole transition
but like it's just interesting that
clone troopers were I mean obviously
they're part of war crimes they're part
of Order 66 they did some pretty
horrible stuff but um but just the fact
that like for this period they were
setting up the the roots of the the
Empire's control over these different
regions I I find it interesting that the
protester was like the Republic forever
because like we get that nod to how the
pharynx people are cut differently back
in an earlier episode but it was really
referring to how they're just like blue
collared people who just want to be left
alone and do things their own way so I
like how there's one guy who just really
really liked this system of government
yeah the Republic
he's like I loved Queen Amidala I loved
her I loved when uh Senator Binks had
that point of order and and engaged in
parliamentary procedure I want I want to
hear what the ET representatives does to
uh to cast the tie-breaking vote to
break the this the super majority Master
Yoda what if we get a Yoda cameo
yeah yeah I'm sure he'll come up next
episode but uh I'm really really really
enjoying this episode uh and this whole
I mean oh like it's just taking its time
uh and I really like how complex this is
getting from on mothma and I want to uh
talk more about what's happening under
man Magma's roof because I think I think
things are gonna get really ugly pretty
quickly for her
um but let's thank our friends on common
goods for sponsoring this episode your
loved ones are complex beautiful
Mysteries but Uncommon Goods knows
exactly what they want whether you're
shopping for a mom dad teenagers in-laws
or your best friends Uncommon Goods
makes it easy to find remarkable and
truly original gifts for anyone Uncommon
Goods once your holiday season to be
stress-free so check out their selection
of thousands of items today here's a few
of our favorite gift set we found on
their site Tommy and his family have
enjoyed decorating their house with the
fall experience collection that's right
fall experiences Galore in bechtold
Manor we've got pumpkins we've got
leaves we've got skeletons we've got
long sleeves so thank you
Uncommon Goods looks for products that
are high quality unique and often
handmade or made in the US they have the
most meaningful full out of the ordinary
gifts anywhere who knows what holiday
shopping will look like this season and
the unique gifts at Uncommon Goods can
sell out fast so shop now and get it
taken care of early uncommon experiences
are more than virtual classes they're
unexpected opportunities to have fun and
connect in new ways from tarot card
readings to romantic map making cooking
and Mixology classes and more no matter
what they are into on comic Goods is the
perfect gift from art and jewelry to
Kitchen home and borrow common goods has
something for everyone not the same like
Lester gives you just find anywhere when
you shop it on Common Goods you're
supporting artists of small independent
businesses to get 15 off your next gift
go to uncommongoods.com wookieleaks
that's uncommongood.com wookieleaks for
15 off don't miss out on this limited
time offer on Common Goods we're all out
of the ordinary all right Tommy let's
talk about mon mothma who can she trust
in her household
based on my knowledge of TV and movies I
think the one person that she can
actually trust is the one person who
seems to hate her the most and that's
her daughter I don't think she can trust
her husband I'd obviously we know she
can't trust her driver we know she's
being you know surveyed by everyone I
don't believe she can trust her old
friend Tay I believe Tay was I think Tay
was trying to fish that information out
of her and I think we're going to find
that tay is uh in no way anyone that you
should say hey have a good day too uh I
I think I think I think it's her
daughter I think her daughter is going
to be her one Refuge see I think I think
you're right about Tay I think Tay is uh
suspicious for sure
um but I am wondering if like if this is
his kind of like a George Orwell
equilibrium Universe where like kids of
the Next Generation they're the first
ones to be born into this indoctrinated
society and he might be able to trust
kids less and because parent is so so
like hostile and passive aggressive with
her I wonder if there's just a sincerity
there with parents no like Karen kind of
knows what she's up to and really he's
just mad that she's not she's not
including them in it right um and he's
like the fact that our marriage has
fallen apart like I genuinely loved you
at some point and I see what you're
doing
and like I understand why you feel like
you have to lead me out of it but like
our politics are the same right I could
have helped you but it's just our
marriage sucks so much I just I have no
more love for you as a person I I for
whatever reason I just parent doesn't
seem to be hiding his his frustration
with her and I kind of feel like we can
trust that from period And I I think
we're gonna see Monmouth I feel a lot of
regret like
I wish that I had done a better job as a
spouse because I might have had an ally
and a partner here and I wonder if uh
her daughter Leda is just gonna be like
my mother is a liar and she's gonna be
like interesting we can't trust the kids
we've got what we like to call a good
old-fashioned Wookie weeks Rift Eric and
I have gone in different directions in
our predictions and only one of us can
be right and the winner well the winner
will continue to show up and do their
job in the same way and the loser will
be killed and hung by a clone trooper oh
my God oh my God tomorrow Morrison will
show it personally to our home yeah hang
us it's crazy with Cameo is doing these
days you can get anything done on Cameo
you really can tomorrow has the choke me
out option for uh 950 dollars
well that's pretty low wow what a deal
it's affordable yeah it depends uh so
when it comes to monmouth's house we
don't really know how much the show's
gonna like twist us on this but it's
just like I've been like surprised by
the level of complexity and depth with
characters before in the show that's not
just how good the writing is right like
we follow so many characters home on
their Journeys like we found CLIA on her
walk today which I just think anybody
can have like some other kind of side
conversation that's happening that's
what what I love about this you're
really giving second looks at every
character looking at everything they say
with for subtext so enjoyable I I find
these episodes
requiring a second and sometimes third
viewing and not feeling yeah like I'm
only watching them to be able to speak
on them I find them genuinely enjoying
find myself genuinely enjoying taking
the episode in for a second time and
sometimes a third time so thank you Tony
Gilroy thank you tone so next episode
obviously cassian's not gonna spend six
years in prison we're only five years
away from the Death Star blowing up so
how do we think he's gonna get out of
prison next episode
I think
they're they're I have a re I have a i
part of the term broke I have a rogue
Theory uh
uh I think serial he's going rogue may
get him out of prison in order to bring
him to justice as Cassie and Andor does
that make sense oh okay like I think
like zero card might be like I'm going
to get you out of prison and then kill
you myself or break or bring you to the
Empire oh my God and be like ah this is
the man who killed the two officers
clear my name expunge my record I think
he's gonna find he's gonna make the link
with all of his research that that uh
grigo frigo grigo whatever his name is
kirgo yeah whatever cassian's fake name
is right now uh he's not in there under
real pretenses as Cassie nandor that's
my rogue Theory my my other guess is
that it might be um oh God why can't I
fail yeah um so I'm thinking yeah you
bring up an interesting thought with uh
with zero Karn at the end we stay
focused on his eyes as he's going
through all these numbers uh it reminded
me a lot of severance as well how you're
just like looking at a screen of numbers
and like who even knows what exactly
your job is or what it's doing uh but uh
it seemed like it was implied that he
might just like see some criminal record
or maybe see a mug shot and recognize
and be like no this is the same guy this
is the same guy and then in that
prisoner transfer uh Cassian could you
know get loose
um but
yeah the fact that Vel needs him dead I
have to wonder if like vel's gonna try
to pull a Walter White thing and just
get him uh executed behind or something
like that or do you think she's gonna
disobey and not follow the order maybe
she doesn't want him dead you know maybe
she maybe she does feel like he saved
her life from skiing like and what he
was gonna do yeah yeah that's totally
possible uh she might have like an
affection for him or see a use in him
you know like
um but I also wonder like what prison
he's going to be in there are some shots
of like at least a labor camp in the
trailer where they're all wearing white
and they're Barefoot and that might be
where he's sentenced and maybe there is
like a prison break or something like
that maybe there's like a rebel faction
from within there maybe that's why they
go to sagarera and so they tell sagrari
all right we just need this guy you got
to break him out of prison
like that I think would be the most
exciting version of this I want to see
sagarera uh blow up in a prison and so I
was like there's not enough prisoners
that I need and they're like well
there's this um tentacled figure who's
in uh solitary confinementation
I'm listening
that's why you can't breathe is because
he gets so excited about the poor guy
he's so exasperated
on themselves ah man
well we will see we'll see uh I think
the next few episodes might be a whole
Prison Break Arc I'm very excited we'll
leave it there for this episode of
WikiLeaks and again my Easter egg
breakdown is coming tomorrow and Tommy
and I will be back next Wednesday with
our reaction to episode eight of it or
you can follow me at eavos follow Tommy
and Tommy bechtold follow me Rockstar
subscribe to WikiLeaks wherever you get
your podcast thank you for watching and
we are broken
foreign